what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back once again with another
installment of the Beyond Omega level
character series a series where we focus
on the most powerful beings to exist
encounter book form and in this video we
are covering none other than yellow
lantern Superman which is basically what
the name implies Superman with a yellow
Lantern ring so as we always do we have
to explain what the concept of a yellow
ring is make sense of all this stuff so
you guys understand what we're talking
about if you don't read Green Lantern
so when DC Comics DC has what's called
the emotional spectrum which is an
energy field comprised of all emotion in
the DC Universe and consists of rage
greed willpower hope compassion love and
fear now in thal Sinestro a member of
the universal peacekeeping force known
as the Green Lantern's had used his ring
to rule his planet with an iron fist he
was banished from the Corps and turned
away from the will power aspect of the
emotional spectrum after being sent to
the planet chord in the antimatter
universe
Sinestro formed a yellow Lantern ring
which tapped into the fear aspect of the
emotional spectrum and returned as one
of the Green Lantern's most notable
enemies following several defeats
Sinestro eventually formed his own Corps
as an antagonist to the Green Lantern's
setting in motion the story known as the
Sinestro Corps war if you guys wanted to
learn more about that we cover videos
every Sunday
there is a massive playlist down in the
description put all kinds of green
lantern stuff fun fact
halloween is coming up i meant to finish
blackest night by the time halloween
came around before october ended i ended
up discovering that blackest night would
run after halloween
so we're doubling up we're covering
Green Lantern blackest night all
throughout the week in addition to our
Marvel and DC stuff so that we can
finish it in time for Halloween
it just makes good sense the story is
about zombies are the Black Lantern
rings having said all of that the yellow
Lantern ring chooses its wearers based
on the ability to instill fear in others
and the power level of the yellow power
ring is determined by the amount of fear
its user is able to channel through it
and it has no upper limit many of the
abilities conferred by the yellow power
ring are similar to the powers of the
other Lantern cores like flight and
energy and force field projection and
hard light constructs however there are
abilities specific to yellow lanterns
like the
to probe the mind of their opponents
discover their greatest fears and
amplify those fears to cause their
victims to experience immense
psychological torture as an extension of
this ability yellow lanterns can uncover
and even erase the thoughts and memories
of others and can exercise a degree of
control over others as well now there
are certain weaknesses of the yellow
power ring first and foremost as is the
case with all power rings that they only
have a finite amount of energy and
require a recharge once that energy is
depleted furthermore yellow Lantern
rings are severely weakened and their
ability to communicate with one another
is greatly impeded in the presence of a
Blue Lantern ring that draws its power
from the emotion of hope now as
impressive as these powers are on their
own we now have to imagine them being
possessed by Superman who on his own is
clearly an omega-level character now I'm
not gonna spend a whole lot of time
going over Superman's powers because I
assume then unless you've intercepted
this transmission from a far-off galaxy
far far away that you probably know who
Superman is and know what his powers are
now the long and short of Superman's
powers is that he has super strength
with no defined upper limit he's
virtually indestructible he has frost
breath he has heat vision he can fly you
guys get where I'm going with all this
stuff
so what we're dealing with here is a
crazy powerful character being further
augmented by the addition of an artifact
that's going to bestow him with even
more powers now as far as I can find
Superman has had possession of a yellow
Lantern ring twice in DC's comic history
once in the main DC continuity and once
in a non continuity story now even
though it happened later I'm gonna start
with the time the Superman had a yellow
lantern room in DC continuity because
there's really not much to cover this
actually happened quite recently in
Superman rebirth issues 29 and 30 in the
current run of his story now I actually
have a video going over this story in
all the ones that came before it in
pretty good detail I mind you if you
want to go back and check it out but to
summarize parallax which is basically
the living embodiment of fear in the DC
Universe comes to earth and starts
possessing and kidnapping children now
when several children have gone missing
Superman goes on a mission to find them
and finds out the parallax was using the
children as bait to lure Superman into a
trap so that you could possess him
thinking that if you possess Superman's
body he'd be virtually indestructible
now after initially refusing parallax
Superman willingly allows himself to be
possessed
when parallax starts draining the life
force from the kids that he captured and
so as a result
Superman is transformed into a yellow
lantern now what happens after this is
honestly a bit anticlimactic as the
yellow lantern Superman is attacked by
the original yellow lantern Thal
Sinestro who's trying to reinstate a
relax as he had done in the past so that
he could once again reach the height of
his powers and since parallax is a
living embodiment of fear which is a
pretty huge source for the yellow
lanterns Sinestro is kind of hoping to
pull it off now what I mean by this
being anticlimactic is that we don't
really get to see an epic battle between
Sinestro and the parallax possessed
Superman because Sinestro enlists the
help of the weaponers of cord
to help them subdue parallax which is
exactly what happens parallax and
Superman are soon separated and were
really left without much to go on as to
what he would be capable of in this
brief of hereit's but as I said earlier
we actually have another story to draw
and albeit one that is not in continuity
in the injustice series of comics if
you're not familiar with the injustice
comics they're based on the universe
created in the video game injustice gods
among us where we actually see Joker
kill Lois Lane and drive Superman insane
and then Superman goes on to eventually
be corrupted by Sinestro and join the
Sinestro Corps as a yellow lantern now
once again if you really want an
in-depth account of the events that
happen in the injustice comics I've got
a playlist based on that now we have to
preface this discussion by emphasizing
that this is not the classic version of
Superman but a version from another
reality that may or may not be as
powerful in his base form then the main
line Superman however at the beginning
of injustice it seems that the version
of Superman from that story it's pretty
comparable in terms of power to his
classic versions so I don't think it's
too much of a stretch to use his feats
as a yellow lantern to give ourselves an
idea of what classic Superman could do
as well so while he has a yellow Lantern
ring Superman is able to basically shrug
off a blast from ganthet one of the
guardians of the universe which are
extremely powerful entities so much so
that they would surely be classified as
being beyond omega-level themselves to
give you guys some perspective in the
story of war of the Green Lantern's
which I'm not gonna spoil because we're
gonna get to it on our videos on Sunday
fit probably the most powerful of the
guardians of the universe manages to
hold off the entirety of the Green
Lantern Corps by himself
it's a crazy Display of power it's one
of the most insane things we've ever
seen but following this Superman grabs
both ganthet and mojo the living
sentient planet responsible for choosing
new Green Lantern's when one of them
died and flies them both into the Sun
and destroys them well this is pretty
much all we have to go on given how
briefly Superman has ever been possessed
by a yellow Lantern ring we can still
just hell from this feat that he's going
to be well above Omega level which makes
sense given that Superman on his own is
Omega level but the fact that a yellow
lantern Superman can destroy an entire
planet and a being who could probably
wipe out the universe could likely do so
that any number of planets that he chose
to which basically means that our
definition of beyond Omega level as
being a universal threat qualifies
Superman to fit this category so it's
pretty insane the kind of power he
possesses what I'd be curious to see is
could yellow lantern Superman take on
someone like the spectre who is the
representation of God's vengeance in the
DC Universe it's literally just if God
was pissed off and was coming for you it
would be the spectre like it's Judas
beast the spectre is an absolute monster
we should make a video about him and we
should do a video about Yuga Khan anyway
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain to make sure you guys
with the sub button to become part of
the robbed Court if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]